تسارع في اعمال بناء مشروع حدائق الملك
عبد الله العالميه غرب الرياض نسبه
الانجاز للمشروع الضخم تجاوزت الاربعين في
المئه منذ عام 2019 عندما عملت امانه
الرياض على مواءمه المشروع مع اهداف رؤيه
انجاز جميل جدا
من ناحيه اول شيء من ناحيه هندسيه وبخبره
الهندسيه هذا ما يسمى ان تبدا في 2019
وتنتهي في انجاز من قطع النظير باربعين في
المئه في خلال فتره وجيزه وانت تستهدف
ايضا 2024 لانهاء المشروع وهو مشروع نادر
وفريد من نوعه تصميم رائع جدا متحف نباتي
يعني عالمي على مستوى العالم ويعكس صوره
ايجابيه عن المملكه وهو احد ايضا احد
جوانب السياحه للمملكه
فسيكون هالمشروع ايضا ليس فقط
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ولكن ايضا
للعالم سيضيف قيمه مضافه للسياحه السعوديه
سيضيف قيمه مضاعفه مضافه للمواطن السعودي
لمعرفه انواع النباتات انواع الاشجار هذه
صور تخيليه للشكل الذي سيكون عليه المشروع
بعد الافتتاح لا يمكن تجاوز التصميم
الفريد لحدائق الملك عبد الله العالميه
والذي حصد عده جوائز عالميه نظيره تصاميمه
الابداعيه للحدائق التي تضم مئه وستين الف
شجره تمثل الفا واربعمائه نوع من النباتات
المحليه والمستورده
بالاضافه الى ان الحدائق العالميه ستشكل
بمساحتها الممتده على اكثر من مليونين متر
مربع مركزا مهما للاحداث الترفيهيه
والوطنيه الكبرى فانه يعد مختبرا واسعا
للباحثين العلميين في التغيرات المناخيه
بالعالم عبر سبع حدائق نباتيه تمثل الحقب
الزمنيه القديمه وسبع حدائق اخرى تقدم
نماذج من الترفيه المرتبط بالتعلم مع
حديقه الوادي التي تحوي عناصر الثروه
البيئيه
للسعوديه باذن الله بنهايه العام القادم
202 بدايه 25 باذن الله سيكون انتهاء
المشروع والبدء تشغيل باذن الله ستكون
الحدائق العالميه الواقعه بالقرب من مشروع
الجديه معلما جديدا للعاصمه الرياض ومعززا
مهما للحركه الاقتصاديه بالبلاد باصوله
الاستثماريه حيث يتوقع ان تقترب التكلفه
الاجماليه للمشروع من ملياري ريال من
الرياض نواف عزيز العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات